bien
un gran avance para la representación de
las personas trans bélgica tendrá la
primera ministra transgénero en la
historia de europa es petra de schutter
del partido verde quien será viceprimera
ministra y ministra de empresas públicas
y función pública me enorgullece que en
bélgica y la mayor parte de la unión
europea tu identidad de género no te
define como persona ni se convierte en
un problema espero que mi nombramiento
como ministra y viceprimer ministra
pueda abrir el debate en países donde
todavía no se contempla su nombramiento
responde a su hoja de vida siendo una
reputada investigadora biomédica y tras
haber ostentado importantes cargos de la
política europea abriendo así camino a
la comunidad trans
[Música]
el 1 de octubre entró en vigor en mexico
la ley de etiquetado claro una
legislación que para la organización
panamericana de la salud convierte a
méxico en un ejemplo para el mundo en
mexico un tercio de la población sufre
obesidad con esta ley y el país busca
que los ciudadanos comprendan lo que
comen como demuestra este tuit del
instituto de salud pública la mayoría el
sodio que ingerimos se encuentra en
productos procesados en bebidas
azucaradas y refrescos un consumo alto
de sodio incrementa el riesgo de
hipertensión con el etiquetado para la
salud infórmate y elige saludablemente
méxico se inspira en una legislación
chilena que cumple cuatro años y que ya
ha demostrado que consigue reducir el
consumo de productos no saludables
la ingeniería consigue contrarrestar los
efectos de las mareas en venecia el
sistema de defensa contra inundaciones
conocido como maus consiguió proteger a
venecia de una marea impulsada por
fuertes vientos y lluvias los vecinos lo
celebran hoy es un día importante
histórico porque deberíamos estar
inundados de agua ahora mismo y al
contrario estamos secos y esto me parece
algo muy destacado la construcción llega
siete años tarde y está preparada para
proteger a venecia de mareas de hasta
tres metros y evitar imágenes como las
del 2019
el forest green roberts es un club de
fútbol inglés especial al llegar a sus
instalaciones aparecen paneles solares
cargadores de coches eléctricos un menú
vegano patrocinadores de empresas
sostenibles y el pasto es orgánico por
este motivo ha sido catalogado por la
fifa como el club más sostenible del
mundo
el pueblo que nos acoge creo que tiene
el mayor índice per cápita de
restaurantes vegetarianos del reino
unido creo que los aficionados que nos
visitan han generado de este ambiente
lo que impulsa esta iniciativa está
llamando la atención de personas
comprometidas como héctor bellerín
futbolista español del arsenal de la
primera división inglesa con su
inversión van a construir un nuevo
estadio completamente de madera
en la zona continental de australia han
vuelto los demonios de tasmania 3000
años después de su extinción
por el momento han liberado a 26 de
estos mamíferos carnívoros conocidos por
su rugido fuerte sus poderosas
mandíbulas y su ferocidad unas
características que sin embargo no les
hacen peligrosos para los humanos